FOUR OF  THE
BOARDS, EKMAN-LARSSON HELD ITY D
CHANCE TO OPEN THE SCORING.
PETTERSSON STICK HANDLING I GAMR
EITHER A CHANGE. AGAIN.
HUGHES WRIST SHOT, TIPPED  COME.
TWO POWER PLAY GOALS IN THE LAST
TWO GAMES.
YOU
AND NOW A SHOT
ALL ALONG, KNIGHT ABLE TO MAKE
THE SAVE.
NOT AND MARTIN HELD STEADY
WITH THE LEFT LEG TO MAKEED THE
GOAL BUT IT'S 1-0 VANCOUVERAVE
>> John S: A LONG SHOT.
NOW MOTTE INTERCEPTS AND HE'LL
BEHIND THE NET.
HARD PASS TO POOLMAN.
AHEAD TO BOESERRONED LAMMIKKO F.
TIPPETT PLAYS IT BEHIND THE
GOAL.
MAXIM MAMIN WAS THERE.
NOW TIPPPP JUSTIN BAILEY GETTING
A CHANCE.LARSHAD, WHEN
A STARBERDEAU, IN POSITION TO
INTERCEPT.
BARKOV SHOVELS SEE REINHART TIP
THAT ONE FOR FLORIDA.TAY WITH M.
SENT ONE RINK-WIDE.
GOBBLED UP BY
CHIASSON WHO DUMPS IT
FAR SIDE.
THIS PUCK WAS HIT WHEN I WAS EX
SAYING ALMOST 3,000 GAMES, HE
HAS OVER 2,000 GAMES WHEN PERFE
STOP SAM REINHART.
MAKE THE SAVE AND GET THE
WHISTLE AT
AHEAD TO]
>> John S: AFTER LAMMIKKO AND
MOTTE RAN INTOO PLAYED IN OVERT
GAME  TO THE BENCH, ERTIME.
CAN THE CANUCKS
THREE MINUTES AND 19 SECONDS IN
>> John S: BROCK BOESER TO LEAD
OFF THE SHOOTOUT FOR AND
AND MARTIN WITH THE LEFT PAD AS
HUBERDEAU TRIED TO DO A
OUT.
HE'S B B YOU GET ELIAS  MARTIN,
SCORES AS HE DEKED TO THE
BACK
COLLAPSES, AND THAT GIVES
LUNDELL SOME ROOM ONTHREE, AND
BEAT KNIGHT AS HE TRIED TO GO
BY THE TIME HE GOES TO THE
BACKHAND SPENCER KNIGHT IS THERE
AND HUGHES HAS NO ROOM TO G G